yeah yeah i remember vietnam and my
entire family came with me so
we have like tons of generations in the
family like we have a big family
oh really yeah like yeah like my mom and
dad obviously
and my sisters were all went through the
vietnam war and then we have my middle
sisters who went through like
the aftermath of the vietnam war and
then we have me who was like
coming to america damn that's all in one
family that's [ __ ]
nuts yeah so nobody understood each
other nobody gave a [ __ ] what each other
felt like because
everybody had different life experiences
you know huh it was hard like
and then i go to i go to like my
american school and they have like
feelings and their mom's like hugging
them and like
like if they didn't like their lunch
they would throw it away and i was like
you can throw your food away you don't
think i'm like looking up like my mom's
somebody's watching me i gotta eat all
this [ __ ] even if it's spoiled i'll
throw it up later
yeah but and then i go home and i tell
them like hey like my friends aren't
getting hit
and they're not like kneeling on rocks
like
and my family like all right cool yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you want to go over there yeah go ahead
isn't that crazy though
like uh i think that's the
the how how insane everybody's life
experiences can be so different in this
country yeah
and that's where you know i i talk about
this um
where i had a conversation with somebody
about asking me about masks right
and they were asking about this
comparison to
how it is in asia and they go well in
asia people wear masks right i was like
well
for me anyways this is how i see it this
is not i didn't read this anywhere or
i'm not coming from a scientific
standpoint this is my perspective in my
life
um because i have traveled across asia
and i've seen everything um
this country's basis of what nationalism
is is scattered
what what people believe in national
pride in the united states is going to
be different from
the person next to me to the person down
the street in asia it's a little more
cohesive i'm not saying everybody
has the same idea idea but their
identity as a nation is very very
similar
like for me me as a asian american kid
that grew up in sacramento in california
my
idea of what an american is doesn't
really have a face right it's somebody
who wants to
pursue their life here and whatever
happiness and whatever dream that they
want yeah but there's somebody out in
the south that's going to be like
i agree with that too but it's only for
white people yeah so
this country's identity is so it's so
scattered was it
it's a good and a bad you know it's it's
scattered because
it's not really an indigenous country
it's
it's it's of everybody coming here and
everybody has different views and
different experiences you know
i was told different stories by their
mom and their grandma and like is
treated differently you know so it's
hard to
compare america to anywhere else and
also america sees a nation as
borders americans don't travel as much
as they should
culture in europe culture and asia
you're all over the place people
identify themselves with culture
so like in asia if you're vietnamese you
go to thailand you know you're
vietnamese because you
you have different tastes and food you
talk a little different whatever
but you don't see it as like i don't
know america is just kind of sets
themselves apart
so much yeah and they take pride in
setting themselves apart
and i think that is a uh weakness of
ours is not really something to be
prideful of i think we need to
see the rest of the world more to be
able to understand ourselves i mean it's
hard too for people here just because
i think we we can even go further back
of how this country was started yeah
this country was started through
it's kind of impossible to have like you
know
like definitive pride but like pride in
which part of the nation pride in which
pride from what house like you know so
it's it's
it's crazy but like the whole mass thing
it's quite [ __ ] simple
okay oh for sure it's quite [ __ ]
simple in asia people wear it when
they're sick when they have a cold